今日はドクター始めた暑くて頭おかしくなりそ愛媛産 youtube の一時代を
つくった前節のこれ知ってますでしょうかこちら
鉄球でございませ機汚染度に熱心で何かするってどうかめちゃくちゃやってた月が
youtube にあったんですけども
ドクターズに知ってるんですよ鮮度の鉄球
触ると熱いんですよ
ん
めっちゃ普通の事いいましたけども結構あの冗談抜きで本当に危ないんですよて指で
今日は実験する風に見せかける風ドッキリやっていこうと思う机の上にあるこの
レパートリーご覧ください鉄球トンロングトーンあっバーナーミリタリーハンズこれ
だけの道具があればもう
体で youtube 見たことある人だったら間違いなくあこの人鮮度の鉄球ね
伏せる動画を撮るなんて思うと思うんですよ
というわけで今日の動画10どの鉄球の実験をしている肇社長に急に呼ばれてその鮮度
の鉄球が体に当たっちゃって
あっちっちドッキリやっていこうと思います私のてこれ本物ませんでも鉄橋たら間違い
なく大やけどどころかも普通に彼にあんな暗いたんで絶対真似しないで下さいじゃあ
今日ケルナー本文じゃないのでそういう超ドッキーなので安心ですヘアだけで手順説明
し
ていきましょうの前で1回戦動画鉄橋見てみますこの子犬は
もやっと1回打つのベランダでやってみましょうか
待って待って待ってっ
まっつぱっぷん普通これで作った世界だったのに
はい今の会また今燃えてるねまで減る分ヘルプミー本当にやばいとしてつけんだっけ
えっあきたきたきたまたこれかえんほうしゃ残っても上手いっ
待ってまた本当に今想像絶する解放さで命の危機を感じだあってるよね使い方を知っ
切った
ちょっと使い方わからないんですよ無理なんよ
はいっ
そう
[音楽]
い
ありがとうございます何が起きるんだ俺行ったら手でつきましたとこうすると
熱してられて鮮度になるっていう色に注目してほしいですこれから来た来たけちだよき
たよきてるきてるきてる
あったんじゃなんか鉄球爆発しましたなんかなんか食うどうでしたねこれ聞いてないよ
詰まってるてっきゅうかと思ったらなんか空洞だったんでほらねっす中の空気が膨張し
て爆発するんで非常に危なかったです
あの皆さん極力で岩根さらにしましょう愛と勇気で別に今回熱するなぁ目的じゃあり
ませんには音してるとこ見て分かったと思うんだがオール自体の色はそんな変色し
なかっ
んですけども本部のもついてめちゃくちゃ赤くなってましたああいう感じでて釣ってね
するとすごい赤くなるんですよ俺はこののこれができてゆーか今でしょものを使って
マジックだからってすごいも鮮度の鉄球ぽさを出していきます塗ってゆく
あー切りたなぁいい
あーなんかまあまあ言われればぽいけどめっちゃ綺麗なんか
ん
寝てるの疲れるなぁ中洲店るってのが濡れんですね明らかに色が剥げてるなあどうすれ
これで脱ぐどうでしょう
美術の授業やって言っています
いやーやっぱ馬瀬口里メタリック感が出ないんだこれだと高さの赤い玉になっちゃうと
絵の具を塗ってみたんですけど違いますね
やっぱ末期で自分にやっていくしかないんだろうな
[音楽]
ニュースもこんな感じでいいのではないでしょうか
これだと網に乗せれっぱ
ge 2
うんどうでしょうかなり赤いメタリックなのではないでしょうか
これくらいが入ると完全にレンズメトリックになってると思いますこれでいきましょう
バッハと言われ
赤いのは企画書まではずっとバレルとも終わりなんで塗ったかをなくしてここには今
どう見ても全部熱された鉄球がありますこれであとはトレっぽい感じで俺が何か鮮度の
鉄橋の実験という学校で出しとけば間違いなくここに来た人はこれを先度的と思い込む
んで恐る恐る
ターゲットの足元にを飛び私ど
無理矢理さを見せてくれるのでしょうかそういう形で鮮度の鉄球落ちて今からねあと家
でやらんし
あれっての上司が持っているターゲットだったら所だったらも入っていた春画さして
帰ってできるかもしんないですけども出せずにゃばけが多いのでさっそく行っていく
ことをみんなでは行こう
[音楽]
はぁ
てへっちょっとドラマというかなさあ
番組ですか鉄の奴らいいからちょっと暑い
アイドルでこちら鮮度の鉄球です完成しました
tan
ついたわけじゃん
[音楽]
よああああわあ
ああああああああ
わあああああ
うわあああああ
ますこれ jin-machine 実はねうん何だよそれ
いいんです
i have in 付
まずまずの反応ではないでしょうかたすぐや河川ドっぽいは強いだろうねぇ
ちょっと金を
なんて声ちょっとターン
な腐らないところに皿ありますというかこれが鮮度が絶景です
この一帯はんっ
[音楽]
これ
いきますいますよ
[拍手]
変な子はこうなりなれなくなり
処分
[音楽]
b
ん
はい骨や数です
ちょっとサボってきたのっていいさー
ずらすその右のそれでこれその右の皆さん入って洗脳的縁に完成しました
[音楽]
ああああああ
わっ
あああああ
あれ今アツイていましたから
[音楽]
えっ
はい協議で船頭の鉄球はユーザそんなさん持ってきたのですかその息の女性の復旧
時で鮮度の鉄球完成しましたてこれをこっつにさせ
わああああああああああ
me
ああああああ
あっはぁし
千怒って思いますけどれないけどセンターの鉄柱
を魅せつけてほどうち復旧でしたあぁんはぁはぁボランチがこれはっけ